after months of online learning most ccs
ccsd students are back in the classroom
but many say they're still struggling
hence tonight's call for change thanks
for joining us at 11 i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis to get that change
one group says it has to start with more
of a focus on students
and their families sasha loftis joining
us from the newsroom with a bit more
sasha
denise and brian parents we spoke with
say they're still not happy with the
district
not only are they calling for change
they have an idea of how to
go about it if mental health isn't
enough
if i'm not enough i don't know what will
be after
a year of distance learning ccsd
families say
they're still struggling the failure
that i have felt as a parent
for 388 days every single day
most students are back in the classroom
either full time or on a hybrid plan
we've continually ranked at the bottom
of the nation but parents tell us
they're still seeing problems that's why
advocacy groups came together thursday
ahead of the district's regular board
meeting to demand
concrete change this failure to
implement the reorganization
they're calling for ccsd to break into
several smaller districts
when you have a district that's so huge
it's got layers upon layers of
bureaucracy and nothing
can get done because everyone is
overwhelmed by the amount of steps it
takes to get something done
another concern school choice they want
kids to have access
to better education options the pandemic
has shown that
students do not have equal access to
high quality education
and so that's what we're calling on but
above all they say
their efforts boil down to one simple
message
they want those in charge to put
children first
we as taxpayers put money out for our
child
why can't we have a voice on how to
spend it
during the meeting trustees and
superintendent dr jesus jarrah also
discussed
next year's tentative budget along with
any legislative items related to
education
they did not respond directly to parent
and students
demands directly tonight reporting live
in the newsroom sasha
loftis 8 news now